spill your Papi's back that's right
Ready Set Radio full effect yo we got
the selected DJ bad blue on the ones the
twos right now man this is something
special that's about to go down on your
radio Las Vegas one of the baddest men
on the two turntables on the planet I'm
gonna just let him do what he does
hey let's go Ready Set radio
that's right ladies and gentlemen deejay
Babu over there
135 later peoples world famous be
junkies in the building they're gonna be
across the street tonight luxor Babu
feel free to grab that mic man right
there you guys turn it on on the mixer
there it is there it is hey man
thank you for blessed with the honor to
share the ready ways with you bro thank
you good you already know I'm just up
here freestyling I wasn't really
compared for this radio clean business I
really wanted to go and play mix and it
bunches up to play but unfortunately you
can't cuss on the radio with a lot of
curse so it's all good next time bro
next time we'll do it from scratch
though which to me is is even better I
like yeah most definitely
Thank You Babu 8:00 tonight make sure
you go check that out duck season four
is on the way catch some dogs on the way
September 27th go get a crown of thorns
while you're at it yes
make sure you go support the entire
native fam remember be strong keys 20
year anniversary night life is coming to
a town near you soon 20 years man
there's a lot going on 2012 and I want
to give a big shout-out to Babu's
Instagram account on Twitter because it
is thorough thanks guys I appreciate
that I was really hard
yo you are like for real the director of
photography over there
I'm trying are you still doing the film
I know I'm bad dusting the floor is like
the reward okay that's what it is man
bad mood tonight he'll be at the Luxor
thanks for coming through let's keep it
moving
Ready Set ready over hip-hop